ناقل سعودي ضخم ستشهده الاجواء السعوديه
قريبا حيث اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان عن تاسيس ناقل جوي جديد
بمسمى طيران الرياض للمساهمه في تطوير
قطاع النقل الجوي تحدث الشركه شركه طيران
الرياض لاطلاق رحلات تصل لاكثر من 100
وجهه حول العالم بحلول العام 2030 وستكون
الشركه مملوكه بالكامل لصندوق الاستثمارات
العامه السعودي ومن المتوقع ان تساهم شركه
طيران الرياض في نمو الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي غير النفطي للمملكه بقيمه تصل
الى 75 مليار ريال
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا هاتفيا وزير النقل السعودي
المهندس صالح الجاسر اهلا بك معالي الوزير
يعني بدايه كيف سيخدم
سيخدم الناقل الجديد طيران الرياض
الاستراتيجيه العامه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وتحديدا في مجال النقل الجوي
شكرا حقيقه هذا فجر جديد لصناعه الطيران
بالمملكه يرسمه اسمه سيدي ولي العهد
الناقل الوطني الجديد الطيران الرياض
سيكون محور عملياته مدينه الرياض
وسيربط الرياض ببقيه العالم
وهو يكمل العمل الذي تقوم به الخطوط
السعوديه التي ستتركز
عملياتها مستقبلا من مطار الملك عبد
العزيز
جدا ببقيه انحاء العالم وبذلك تتكامل
اجراءات تنفيذ الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه في مجال الطيران
واستراتيجيه الطيران المدني بالمملكه
وتبعا لمعه لنا عنه سابقا من تاسيس المطار
الاضخم بالعالم مطار الملك سلمان بمدينه
الرياض معالي الوزير يعني ماذا عن
المنافسه نتحدث هنا عن منطقه الشرق الاوسط
اللي فيها كبرى الشركات التي تعمل بمعايير
عالميه نتحدث عن طيران الامارات عن قطر
ارويز عن الطيران التركي اين كيف فعليا
ستحجز طيران الرياض مكان لها في ظل هذه
المنافسه العاليه
المملكه
بلد شاسع
ويعني
به امكانات كبيره جدا ونمو اقتصادي مضاعف
رؤيه المملكه تمثل نقله كبيره
لاقتصاد المملكه هناك استراتيجيه النقل
والخدمات اللوجستيه التي تستهدف تحويل
المملكه الى مركز اللوجستي عالمي
330 مليون راكب في المملكه بالطيران اكثر
من اربعه ونص مليون طن هناك استراتيجيه
السياحه التي تستهدف الوصول الى 100 مليون
سائح
كل هذه اضافه الى النمور الاقتصادي الكبير
يتطلب عمليه ربط
للمملكه ببقيه العالم ايضا تعزيز جوده
الحياه في مدينه الرياض
وجاذبيتها للاقامه وللاستثمار يتطلب مثل
هذه الربط والمملكه لديها ميزات تنافسيه
سواء بالموقع او عدد السكان او حجم
الاقتصاد او اتساع البلد معالي الوزير كيف
سيواكب تاسيس شركه طيران الرياض خططكم
لتوسيع المطارات وتحديدا مطار الملك سلمان
الملك مطار الملك سلمان سيكون احد اكبر
المطارات في العالم هناك ايضا مراحل من
التوسع
منطلقه بخطوات متتابعه مؤخرا تم افتتاح
الصاله ثلاثه واربعه بمطار الرياض
سيتبعها ان شاء الله خطوات متتابعه توسعات
الى حين افتتاح الكامل لمطار الرياض مطار
الملك سلمان بالرياض باذن الله هل سيكون
هناك توزيع بالادوار بين الخطوط الجويه
السعوديه وطيران الرياض يعني واحد يكون
مركز عملها بجده والاخر بالعاصمه
بالضبط طيران الرياض سيكون مركز عملياته
بالرياض والخطوط السعوديه ستركز عملياتها
باذن الله في مدينه جده طبعا هناك مراحل
انتقاليه بانه بناء شركه طيران الرياض
ستاخذ بعض الوقت وايضا اتمام بناء الخطوط
السعوديه
يعني مركز العمليات في جده يحتاج وقت
فلذلك هناك مرحله انتقاليه ولكن الهدف هو
ان ان يركز طيران الرياض لخدمه يعني مركز
عمليات الرياض وكذلك بالنسبه للخطوط
السعوديه في جده نعم هل هنالك من مده
زمنيه او وضع توقيت ان تصبح شركه طيران
الرياض قيد العمل
ان شاء الله يتم الاعلان قريبا عن معلومات
اضافيه من قبل صندوق الاستثمارات العامه
عن هذا الموضوع شكرا جزيلا لك معالي وزير
النقل السعودي المهندس صالح الجاسر على
هذه المداخله
وينضم الينا حول نفس الموضوع هنا في
الاستوديو الخبير في قطاع الطيران المهندس
طارق العيد اهلا بك مهندس طارق معنا هنا
في استوديوهات الرياض يعني بدايه ما اهميه
وجود ناقل جوي بمستوى عالمي ينطلق من
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
مثل ما تفضل معي الوزير صالح الجاسر في
البدايه عن ميزات التنافسيه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه سواء موقع سواء مساحه
سواء عدد سكان قبل ذلك كله احب يعني ابارك
لنا جميعا يعني كشعب سعودي وكقياده رشيده
في هذا التدخين المبارك يعني نقله نوعيه
جدا وجود هذا الناقل بالامس القريب سمعنا
بتدشين خبر مطار الملك سلمان في الرياض
وباهداف طموحه جدا عاليه كبيره 120 مليون
مسافر في 2030 180 مليون مسافر كمرحله
لاحقه سته مدارس بني تحتيه قويه كل هذه
الامكانيات الهائله والضخ الملياري
[موسيقى]
الطيران كل مكان هناك عندك مرونه تفتح
وجهات اكثر مرونه انك تبدل بين الوجهات
مرونه انك تلغي ويعني تدير عمليه الاختلال
في التوازن التشغيلي كل الاخبار اللي طلعت
مسبقا ما احد لا احد يعني مصرح له بالنفي
او الاثبات سواء الجهات المصرحه لها
وصاحبه الشان فيها
كان قال بانه سيتم الاعلان عن المزيد من
المعلومات بالقاده من الايام ولكن اود ان
اسالك عن المنافسه خاصه المنافسه
الاقليميه هناك منافسه عالميه الشرق
الاوسط ربما يصبح الان مركز لاهم شركات
الطيران الى اي مدى وجود الشركه الطيران
الرياض سيساعد بذلك
مراكز الابحاث لدى الابحاث بعد الدراسات
الابحاث في جامعه هارفرد وبعد دراسات
الابحاث من بوينج اشاره انه الشرق الاوسط
ينمو بشكل تصاعدي مثيره سريعه جدا لم يسبق
لها المثيل كنوع حركه نقل جوي لم يسبق لها
مثيل في اي مكان في العالم كنسبه وتيره
نمو السوق يستوعب ولا زال يحتاج بعض من
التنظيم واساس التنظيم القاره اللي عندنا
هنا ما شاء الله في الشرق الاوسط من اكبر
دول شرق الاوسط المملكه العربيه السعوديه
واكبر دول الخليج نوع من التنظيم خطوط
سعوديه تمسك جده شركه الطير رياضيه امسك
الرياض وجسر جوي وكلما قلت الهبس او
التوقفات كل ما كان في عندك مجال انك
تستقطب مسافرين اكثر الاهداف طموح
اختراويه واعلن اعلن عنها اهداف وظيفيه
اعلن عنها اهداف اقتصاديه اعلن عنها 75
مليار ريال من ناتج غير النفطي الناتج محل
الاجمالي اتكلم 200 الف وظيفه تساهم فيها
ايه
ناقل جوي جديد بهذه الضخامه وبم معايير
دوليه يعني المزيد من فرص العمل للسوق
السعوديه احسنت عندنا الاسطوره عندنا لو
مسكنا اي نوع من انواع الطائرات الطيارات
ضيقه البدن ما هو البدن الواسع
طائره واحده تنتج لك ما يقل عن 35 وظيفه
مباشره ما بين طاقم صيانه وملاحين وطيارين
وملاخره فما بالك في الوظائف الغير مباشره
تتكلمي عن الوظائف السياحه الوظائف خدمه
المسافرين بشكل عام الخدمات اللوجستيه نقل
الاركاب الضيافه
التشغيل والصيانه للمطارات وما خلافه 200
الف وظيفه اعتقد انه هدف طموح ويعني
مقدور للوصول باذن الله مع هذه الرؤيه
طموحه وحسب دراسه الخبره ما في اي ارقام
مؤكده لحد الان لكن عدد السور الطائرات
الان في المكرمه السعوديه تقريبا قرابه
300 طائره
توقع في 203 انه يتجاوز الرقم الى 400 الى
500 الطائره في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بوجود الاسطوره الجديد شكرا جزيلا لك
الخبير في قطاع الطيران المهندس طارق
لعيني شكرا يعطيك العافيه